which is transier would you say spinach
or Bud Light which is more likely to
make you a little bit light in the
loafers which is more likely to push you
toward the rainbow flag would it be
spinach would it be uh escarole would it
be broccoli rabe or would it be a can of
Bud Light Bud Light is sick of the jokes
Bud Light has had enough of the jokes
about them
and Anheuser-Busch is saying it was just
one can this is their new every day they
have a new response every day you get a
letter or a commercial about horses or
this or that
so here's what Bud Light has said now
this is through their distributor they
say
this was one single can given to one
social media influencer it was not made
for production or sale to the general
public this can is not a formal campaign
or advertisement leave us alone leave
Britney alone and stop it in reality
they say the Bud Light can was can
posted by a social media influencer that
sparked all the conversation was
provided by an outside agency without
anheuser-busch's management awareness or
approval since that time the lack of
oversight and control over marketing
decisions has been addressed and a new
VP of Bud Light marketing has been
announced okay great so this is the
biggest walk back we've seen yet
certainly better than when Bud Light
doubled down on the campaign certainly
better than the letter from the CEO
where he basically just said I love the
military stop boycotting us certainly
better than the horse's commercial
better even than the temporary
suspension of this VP of marketing
they're saying look this was obviously a
mistake they're insinuating this was
obviously a mistake I don't we did it
wasn't it wasn't even a campaign it
wasn't even it's not even what you think
it is just
okay
you're so close
say you're sorry
say you're sorry say it was the wrong
decision and say and this is the crucial
part
say that men and women are different
say that men can't really be women
say that you oppose transgender ideology
that is the only way to fix this
you're so close every day every three
days you inch a little bit closer to
doing that
which would probably work
but you don't ever quite get that you're
so cautious and
you think Bud Light That by being
cautious and clever in your language
that you're going to be able to straddle
the fence here you're not your sales
numbers are just going to get worse and
worse and worse it's not like the sales
numbers declined and then they've kind
of just stayed there that would be a
problem for Bud Light too they keep
declining
because there's no Middle Road on this
issue
to quote a certain speech from CPAC this
year that caused a lot of consternation
there is no conciliatory middle way on
the issue of transgenderism some issues
there there is a middle way this one
there isn't one
either men and women are different or
they're not different either women get
their own bathrooms or they don't get
their own bathrooms
you you
maybe could have avoided the issue had
you avoided the issue I'm not saying
that every company in America needs to
go send out a statement of metaphysics
and anthropology okay
but you inserted yourself into the issue
and you offended your whole customer
base and you said something that's
manifestly wrong and it's a it's a
urgent social issue that is having
harmful effects for lots and lots of
people really for everybody involved
especially for the people who've Fallen
prey to this confusion
so now you're in it
and the only way out is going to be
through
the only way out Bud Light you can do it
you say I'm sorry
we were wrong
transgenderism isn't real
come out and say it
we'll drink Bud Light again I drank like
three Bud Lights a year but I'll drink
Bud Light again if Bud Light came out
and said it
it would be better to me
than had Bud Light never waded into
these Waters in the first place if Bud
Light came out and said we're sorry this
was wrong transgenderism's fake men
can't really become women
I would buy more Bud Light than I did
before because that would send a message
to the rest of corporate America
which is that
if you come out and defend the truth and
Sanity and reason
we will have your back you will have an
audience space there it would encourage
other companies so do it Bud Light
do it I'll buy a case or two I don't
know I'll at least talk about it right
now head on over to puretalk.com Knowles
we all know about the big wireless cell
companies out there they lock you into
these horrendous contracts and then if
you try to get out of them early they
tack on outrageous charges which is why
I love puretalk Wireless where there are
no hidden fees no contacts and no hassle
pure talk to us customer service team
has helped so many people make the
switch in as little as 10 minutes they
were even able to keep their own phone
number I'm so glad that I use Pure Talk
frankly just the us-based customer
service team would be enough for me but
you get the same networks that you're
using right now you can get unlimited
talk text plenty of data the price is
much much lower it's so simple it's so
easy head on over to puretalk.com enter
promo code Knowles Canada wlas to save
50 5-0 off your first month that is
puretalk.com promo code Knowles k n o w
l e s b like me use Pure Talk Pure Talk
is simply smarter Wireless the Nashville
PD is continuing to Stonewall on the
manifesto of the trans identifying
shooter who shot up a Christian
Elementary School
I have been defending the Nashville PD
in part because of the heroic actions of
the officers but in part because I know
that this is a politically tough case
for them and I know that they've got the
FBI breathing down their necks even
though the FBI the Memphis field office
told the daily wire in the days after
the shooting that the FBI really has no
jurisdiction here there's no evidence
that the FBI should be involved but then
all of a sudden we find out the FBI is
involved and there are all of these
issues about releasing the manifesto for
virtually every other one of these
shootings where there is a Manifesto we
get to read the manifesto we especially
get to read the manifesto if it's an
angry straight white guy who is in any
way right-wing
but in this case
where
all signs seem to point to
transgenderism being at the ideological
factor in the shooting here
we we don't get the manifesto
so what are they saying they say due to
pending litigation filed this week the
Metropolitan Nashville police department
has been advised by Council to hold and
Advance the release of Records related
to the shooting at the Covenant School
for pending orders or direction of the
Court
okay
why do they have to hold it what's the
litigation the litigation is from the
Tennessee Firearms Association
trying to get the manifesto out
so they're saying the the Tennessee
Firearms Association asserts that the
police wrongly denied public records
requests and so they want to get the
manifesto out and the national PD is
trying not to release the manifesto and
then they now their their excuse now as
to why they won't release the manifesto
is that there's pending litigation about
why they won't release the manifesto so
this is obviously a purely political
matter and the the political leadership
that is preventing the Nashville PD from
doing the right thing should be ashamed
of itself and we should see the
manifesto period
did you enjoy that stunning commentary
and that just sparkling hairdo well if
you did you got to subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel ring the
bell click it see you next time
[Music]